as yuri was bringing the spacecraft in
for the the first manual
approach we were just aware that things
were not going right we had another
failure
um which meant the computer screen went
down so tim and i were effectively blind
and that was the point i realized this
approach is
is just not good and yuri actually his
hands started trembling on the
controllers
[Music]
you don't get to choose how and when you
become an astronaut you really have to
wait
until a space agency wants a selection
process
and for me i was very lucky that
happened in 2008
when i was leaving the army anyway i had
the operational experience
3000 hours of flying helicopters and i
thought i'm in the right place to
apply to become an astronaut and i
along with eight and a half thousand
other people filled in the application
form
the hard skills to some degree once
you've passed that first day of testing
they can teach you they can teach you
how to speak russian they can teach you
how to space walk
they can teach you how to fly a soyuz
spacecraft but if you don't get on with
people if you haven't got the soft
skills if you haven't got the
interpersonal skills
then you're not going to be suitable for
the job so the selection process is
making sure
they've got the right type of person to
begin with the moment
when i got the phone call was
incredible because i i thought the phone
call was the rejection
phone call i thought it was a joke at
first
people don't joke about this kind of
thing so of course i was excited i was
elated
this is when you kind of jump on the
conveyor belt ride for two and a half
years
that's going to take you towards that
seat on the soyuz spacecraft
we spent hours training in a simulator
where every known emergency
is thrown at us in the early part of our
training more often than not we would
fail and it's very humbling to be told
that you've come out of a simulator
session and you would have died
failure is the the best teacher and it
makes you work
stronger and better together so that the
next time that happens you survive
before launch you've got moments of
nervousness and anxiety and apprehension
but you really deal with that
before you get on top of the rockets
launch is exciting
it's all about noise power uh nine
million horsepower lifting you off
accelerating at the the rate of the
formula one car
but it's um it's like a fairground ride
on steroids it's something that you can
comprehend and enjoy and and be excited
about
we we came over the pacific and i
remember looking out the window into
this blackness of the pacific ocean
and the first thing that happened was
the moon rose over the ocean with this
beautiful moonlight glimmering off the
pacific
and it just felt incredibly special to
be able to to see that
and once you're up in space and the
rocket is is horizontal
you're aware of just going at a
phenomenal
speed and the rocket is still
accelerating it's getting up to 25 times
the speed of sound and that's hard to
comprehend
i mean i'd flown fast jets before but
nothing
ever compares to the the acceleration
and the speed
of a rocket and then it stops very
violently you go from 4g to 0g in a
fraction of a second
and then everything goes quiet really
eerily quiet after the noise
of a launch and everything floats
anything that's not strapped down floats
up the sawyers were suddenly flooded
with uh all this sunlight coming in and
again i looked out and there was the
first
sunrise coming up over the earth and
that's when the the colours of the earth
just struck me
and it was absolutely beautiful it's
like this magnificent
blue and green jewel against the vast
blackness of the universe
as yuri was bringing the spacecraft in
for the the first manual
approach we were just aware that things
were not going right we had another
failure
which meant the computer screen went
down so tim and i were effectively blind
yuri was using a small periscope to try
and line himself up
the sun was going down behind us and
reflecting all the light
off the space station so yuri was being
blinded mission control
were distracting him with an awful lot
of chatter from the radio
and and that was the point i realized
this approach is is just not good and
yuri
um actually his hand started trembling
on the controllers he was on this sixth
mission to space so i thought
if yuri's not comfortable with this
situation then then it's really not good
we had yawed off target and were
drifting back
along the space station and actually
came very close
to a collision so yuri thankfully
recognized the danger
backed off got everything lined up again
and brought it in for a textbook
second manual approach so we were just
thankful to be there at that point
a normal day in space is up at about 6
30 at seven o'clock we have a round the
world tag up with all the mission
control centers that
help to plan and coordinate the day on
the space station so that's
houston to huntsville to moscow munich
and tokyo
and then we get on with science the
purpose of the space station is
primarily a laboratory to do science
in microgravity so any scientist wants
to change parameters
pressure temperature humidity whatever
it is and
and do science and find out how that
changes things and in space we've
changed gravity
everything here on earth for four
billion years has evolved
in a 1g environment in space we go to
zero g
and so we're finding out new things
about the human body
about material science how to make metal
alloys that are
light and elastic and have qualities
that we simply can't replicate back here
on earth
and that's helping us to get closer to
lightweight
efficient technologies for engine
aircraft engines for example
or developing drugs for motor neurone
disease parkinson's disease
but in addition to the science we're
also there to explore
so it's about how we can live and work
in space for longer so we can make the
next steps to the moon
and eventually to mars we're still
finding out about the long-term
effects of spaceflight we know that your
muscles and your bone will atrophy and
we've done an awful lot of work over the
years to stop that from happening so
we know how we should exercise in space
because we're trying to stop
our bodies from adapting to space too
much because we need to be fit and
healthy for coming back to earth so we
do about an hour and a half two hours of
fitness
every day as well and we're starting to
get better about the nutrition that we
have
in space as well to stop that but we
also know that our skin ages our
eyesight changes
our immune system becomes depleted and
we're more prone to blood clots and
and these are relatively new things that
we found out i guess the the longest
lasting effect is the radiation dose
because that's
um very hard to quantify what the
effects will be we we get the equivalent
of
eight chest x-rays a day on board the
space station so it's it's not trivial
what's the funniest thing you can
remember happening to you
we're up there for a long period of time
and um you know we're all of a similar
type of personality so we would play
play tricks and jokes on each other um
uh
scott kelly even managed to get a
gorilla suit up on board the space
station i have no idea
how he managed it which was hilarious we
had a lot of
fun with that and so i think that's the
the nice thing about
being in space are those lighter moments
where you actually have some normality
even though you're in this uh incredibly
uh precarious situation
when you were told that you were going
to doing space work how did you feel
about that
things breaking in space you don't
normally like but if it means that
you're going to get the opportunity to
do a space walk then we're all for it
so tim copper and i had to suit up and
go and repair this solar panel at the
furthest edge of the space station this
most people will recognize
is a drink bag but it's a drink bag that
we use when we're out on a space walk
what we have to do before a spacewalk is
fill this up
with water from our water dispenser
inside the space station
and it's got velcro here so we would
stick that on the inside
of our hard upper torso in our spacesuit
and then when we squeeze ourselves into
our
suit it will be resting here we make
sure that this
is just poking up into our helmet so
outside in the space walk we don't have
anything to eat
but we do have something to drink a
space walk traditionally lasts
anywhere between six and eight hours
once we've gone through the effort of
suiting up and all the preparation you
want the spacewalk to try and achieve as
much as possible
you're in this confined environment um
cocooned in it's like being in an ocean
liner
and then when you go out on a spacewalk
it's a bit like just diving off the
ocean liner into the big blue sea
um this you're in this space suit and
you can maneuver yourself around you've
just got a thin visor between you
and the vacuum the risk is palpable when
you're hanging off the space station but
it's also um
an incredibly calm serene environment to
be in
uh it's i've done freefall parachuting
and it's not the same it's not like a
huge adrenaline rush there are moments
certainly when the adrenaline is up
but for the majority of the time it's a
beautiful calm
serene experience being out there and
being able to look around at the
universe
the return to earth is a is a mixture of
uh it's really hurry up and wait because
you undock from the space station and
you feel incredibly vulnerable in this
tiny sawyer's
capsule you've got used to the space
station in its enormity for six months
and the soyuz spacecraft feels very very
small and vulnerable and the first
orbit of earth is actually nothing very
much to do it's very quiet
you're just enjoying your last orbit but
then everything happens in the
in the second orbit that's when you burn
the engines
and this is what's going to start to
bring you back down to earth
because the only reason you're staying
in orbit is because you've achieved
25 times the speed of sound and the only
way to come home is to put the brakes on
so we turn the spacecraft around and
burn the engine in the direction of
travel
and that slows us down but that engine
burn has to be very very accurate
if you burn for too long you're going to
come in too steep
and that could risk damage to the
spacecraft possibly burning up
and if you don't burn for long enough
you're not going to come back you're
going to go through the upper layers of
the atmosphere and back out into space
so we're very cautious when we start the
engine
on a rocket or a spacecraft rather that
has been in space for six months it's a
bit like starting a car after a long
cold winter
and just hoping that it's going to work
okay my job was to do all the mental
arithmetic to work out how to
long to burn the thrusters for if the
primary engine
didn't work so having got my d in maths
at school
i'm always amazed that that task fell on
my hands
but thankfully the engine burn went well
and
we are then set on a course for coming
back to earth the next thing that
happens
in this scheme of things is separation
so the spacecraft is in three parts
but only the descent module is going to
come back to earth the other two modules
will burn up in the atmosphere
so the spacecraft separates itself which
is quite an explosive event
pyrotechnic bolts going off blowing the
spacecraft into three chunks
and then from that moment onwards the
descent module where the three crew
members are sat
is pretty much out of control just
tumbling end over end
waiting for the earth's atmosphere to
pick up the spacecraft
and write it in the correct direction
heat shield first looking out the window
at that point
is it's quite unnerving because you're
you're seeing the earth going over and
over as you're tumbling
and it's also only about 150 200
kilometers
beneath you you've been used to seeing
the earth from up at 400 kilometers so
it suddenly
feels very very close and you're very
aware that you're just
falling like a brick and the whole
re-entry takes about eight minutes
and during that time a ball of plasma
will be forming around the spacecraft
gets up to 1700 celsius outside so
extremely hot outside
and you're very very hot inside because
there's no air conditioning you're
simply recirculating the same air
and trying to get some airflow through
your suit and then
just when you think that's you know
finished and done with the parachutes
open we're still going just over the
speed of sound at this point so when
breaking parachutes come out
it's very very violent and the
spacecraft is flung around
underneath these parachutes and that
lasts for about 20 seconds
until we get a big jolt of the main
canopy
opening and then 15 minutes before we
impact with the ground
what do you think is the future for
space travel we're already
set on going back to the moon and we've
got firm plans for that and europe is
very much part of those plans so we'll
see that happening over the next decade
we'll see a return to the moon but not
with an intention just for
a two week mission this is with the
intention for a sustained
and sustainable presence so building
habitation modules on the surface of the
moon
using the resources in situ i think
commercial companies such as
spacex and blue origin are doing great
things
in space because what they're doing is
reducing the cost of access to space by
pushing technologies forward and also
by commercializing low earth orbit it
allows the the national space agencies
to be able to use their resources
for doing deep space exploration and
that will be a stepping stone
onto mars which will probably be the
2030s and beyond to have the first human
missions to mars
space holds a special place in many
people's hearts in terms of it's a place
where
you can dream you can explore your mind
can wonder about the possibilities i
think it's only natural that we are
drawn to that
when you ask people you know what would
you like to be in and and many young
boys and girls say
an astronaut you can understand why
because it's it's
the future it's exploration it's pushing
those boundaries
[Music]
i looked up and i could see two guys
with a
pkm belt fed
russian machine gun and they were
hammering down
on the lads my rifle only shoots 1500
meters
so i had to i call it lobbying
i lobbed the bullet in